for me be honest with you i don't have
balance i mean i i don't seek it and nor
do i have it to be candid with you i
mean at any given time
you know there's certain areas of my
life that are spiking compared to other
ones and i think just the people around
me know that there's gonna be times
where i'm gonna have an abundance of
time with my family there's gonna be
times where you know i'm just going nuts
with work or whatever it is in my life
so i don't really have balance i don't
seek it i think balance is boring
and i think people that have a ton of
balance probably aren't achieving a
whole lot or accomplishing a lot or
loving a lot like i like a little drama
i like a little intensity i like stress
and so
i'm not even really after that so i
think people that are seeking that are
seeking something at least for me i
don't know how gc feels about it but for
me it's not something i want nor do i
know that perfect balance exists for
anybody i mean i think you're probably
pretty balanced when you're dead but you
know when i'm living and i'm alive
there's just different areas of my life
any given time to demand more of my time
or that i'm demanding more of my time in
and so at least for me i don't have